[Applaudissements]
on a donc une nouvelle fois on s'est mis
dans vous savez je surveille toutes les
télévisions françaises chaque jour mais
pour rien louper maintenant je suis
carrément à l'intérieur pour être sûr de
vraiment pas louper une image tout ça
c'est le squattage de la télé regarder
myriam el khomri est notre invité ce
matin bonjour bonjour merci de me
recevoir
quand c'est une première merci d'être
venu nous voir donc on peut leur
nouvelle et comme une fois le cd et
vivent pas combien soirée une fois non
mais combien
mais la belle connerie en cdd alors cdd
donc si on leur nouvelle combien après
ça cdi devient un cd vierge le des deux
cdd veut dire dominique ça peu de gens
le savent déjà pris à la fac
nous avons analysé décrypter cette
action ralentir regardez bien le danseur
surtout de gauche avant rouge qui se
situe à la gauche de votre écran il
réalise un geste posé un geste connu
lorsque qui se foulent la cheville lors
de cette danse et se retrouve au sol
pour bien comprendre on va revoir la
palette 3d au ralenti observez de
danseurs à part sur un mauvais appui de
la jambe gauche qui vend su créer un
déséquilibre de l'ensemble de son épine
dorsale idée complètement désynchronisée
avec son chorégraphe la chevy part il se
tape complètement là on peut le dire la
balle tôt pour les danseurs de gauche ne
déçurent qui malheureusement risque
d'éloigner elle ce danseur delà de leurs
modèles cdu de leur mort dancefloor
surtout pendant un bon moment c'était
l'équipe du dimanche sur canal
comme tous les médias
changement de territoire il ya beaucoup
de symboles dans cette forêt le
territoire qu'on a en indre et loire se
situe dans la région de loches et il ya
mille hectares de bois
[Musique]
adoubé mois 140 c'est quasi sûr combien
de four maximum je vais prendre un joker
monsieur bourdin je vais faire l'appel à
un ami
parce que vous ne le savez pas deux fois
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]